Venus is Earth's nearest neighbor it's
closest to Earth in size and Composition
it's something clearly went awry its
atmosphere is almost entirely carbon
dioxide surface temperatures are a
scorching 460 degrees Celsius hot enough
to melt lead
pressures are 90 bar as crushing as
being one kilometer deep in the ocean
understanding how Venus's atmosphere
turned into a runaway greenhouse boiling
away any oceans and baking the surface
could help astronomers studying other
solar systems they could distinguish
truly earth-like exoplanets from evil
twins like Venus until recently venus is
treacherous surface conditions made the
idea of an extended stay on the planet a
far-off dream in the 1970s and 80s the
Soviet Union pearled mission after
mission to the planet's inferno but none
survived more than a couple hours under
soaring temperatures silicon the
backbone of modern electronics loses its
semiconductor behavior transistors
stopped working
now researchers are developing
microchips made of silicon carbide which
can function at much higher temperatures
they have not been able to put billions
of transistors on a single chip as in
conventional electronics but even with
hundreds of transistors the chips rival
the capabilities of computers from the
early days of solar system exploration
to test the endurance of these chips
researchers used NASA's gear the Glen
extreme environments rigged gear is a
pressurized chamber the size of a
minivan and weighing in at 14 tons it
can simulate the temperatures and
pressures of Venus's surface it can also
mix in eight different gases to create a
venus like atmosphere recently
researchers tested silicon carbide chips
inside gear it functioned well during a
60-day test an ordeal that may have
changed the course of Venus exploration
rather than hiding electronics in heavy
refrigerated pressure vessels
researchers hope that by early next
decade NASA may be able to land simple
unprotect
robots on Venus's surface and instead of
running for a few hours the Landers
could last for months giving us a
glimpse of Venus's surface never before
thought possible one big question they
could help with is Venus geologically
dead or alive many researchers think
that some five hundred million years ago
a catastrophic event covered the
planet's surface in magma and wiped it
clean but that Venus has been pretty
much dead ever since but in recent years
measurements from orbit have detected
spikes and volcanic gases such as sulfur
dioxide and some volcanoes thought to be
dormant have been found to be abnormally
warm signs that Venus might not be as
inactive as we thought there is
unfortunately still a long way to go
until we touch down on Venus's surface
but when we do these resilient
electronics will be crucial in allowing
our robots to take the heat
[Music]
[Music]